bonjour fabien et filippo bonjour merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation sur rt france tout d'abord
votre commentaire sur les tirs de
mortier dans le quartier de stalingrad à
paris
je crois qu'on a une situation qui petit
à petit homme dérivés on sent de plus en
plus le trafic de drogue a proliféré il
s'est déplacé là vers une zone davantage
des ide en ciel et les les citoyens
moment donné il ya des choses qu'ils
n'acceptent plus quand vous sortez avec
des enfants que vous n'êtes pas en
sécurité quand vous êtes pris à partie
matin midi et soir devant chez vous
quand on sait que la police y un sursis
tous les jours mais ne peut pas
interpeller les gens quand on sait que
ben voilà il ya aussi des personnes
supplémentaires qui arrivent sur notre
territoire et danser dans ce territoire
là chaque jour il ya un moment c'est le
ras-le-bol qui s'exprime la violence et
doit rester le monopole de la police ça
il faut le dire très clairement mais il
faut aussi que le gouvernement prenne
conscience qu'il ne peut plus il ne peut
plus laisser de telles situations
s'installer et des risées en se disant
le mal est circonscrit et s'il n'est pas
là il ya le bailleur non il faut frapper
très fort il faut une présence continue
de la police danser dans ces endroits là
et il faut que la justice était le sujet
de d'avant et bien ceux d'une sévérité
implacable avec avec ceux qui profitent
de la faiblesse des autres et de la
misère des autres
d'autant que ce genre de troubles s'est
multiplié ces dernières semaines dans
certains quartiers des policiers qui
sont pris pour cible dans ces quartiers
également à valence notamment encore
récemment le ministre de l'intérieur a
été interpellé hier à l'assemblée
nationale regarder alors monsieur le
ministre
quand allez vous enfin garantir aux
français leur droit à vivre en toute
sécurité
s'il ya des troubles dans certains
quartiers notamment de valence c'est
qu'il ya eu depuis le mois de janvier
madame 495 interpellation 25 trafic de
sucre des manques les essais parce que
plus de la république c'est son travail
vous féliciter de votre gré de votre
action
mais quel décalage avec ce que vivent
les français
qu'en pensez vous faut bien défini pour
est ce qu'il ya un décalage avec ce que
dit justement est la député antoine et
gérald darmanin lui dise il y a
recrudescence de ses troupes c'est
justement parce qu'il ya plus
d'interventions des policiers est ce que
c'est le cas bien entendu qu'il y ait un
décalage mais gérald darmanin et très
doux et non pas pour l'action politique
et faire en termes de polices mais pour
sa communication et donc il sait très
bien jongler avec les chiffres
quand vous parlez de problèmes de
sécurité circonscrit dans un quartier
précis et que lui vous répond avec des
statistiques sur l'ensemble d'une ville
ou d'une agglomération sur une période
de quasiment 5 mois et bien à ce moment
là entre le chiffre brut que lui vous
donne 500 qui peut paraître
impressionnant et la réalité de ce qui
s'est passé dans cet endroit là et des
dérives qui ont continué
vous comprenez que c'est irresponsable
de sa part parce qu'ils jouent avec les
sentiments des gens il accroît ce
décalage là entre le discours du
gouvernement et la réalité mais ça c'est
une constante de ceux de ce quinquennat
la d il continue au lieu de regarder la
réalité en face et de parler des
difficultés concrètes qu'ils rencontrent
sur le terrain est bien d'alimenter
cette défiance la la criminalité qui
étend au sein même dans les secteurs
ruraux en france est-ce que vous pensez
que le gouvernement a failli sur cette
question de la sécurité il reste encore
un an
bien entendu bien entendu mais on n'a
jamais vu d'action ferme de la part de
ceux de ce gouvernement là sur ce sujet
toutes les propositions que nous à effet
souvenez-vous de ce qu'on disait en
avril 2018 sur la loi asile et
immigration et gérard collomb lui même
quand il est sorti du gouvernement a
reconnu qu'elle ne qu'elle ne servait à
rien tout ce qu'on a produit pour rendre
plus efficient la condamnation et la
reconduite immédiate à la frontière des
gens qui sont en situation de
clandestinité qui arrive en france en
violeur nos nos lois tout ce qu'on a
demandé en plus sur la justice des
mineurs l'abaissement de la de la
majorité pénale tout ce qu'on a demandé
pour renforcer aussi les moyens
d'exécuter la sanction parce que le
problème de la justice aujourd'hui c'est
aussi un problème avant tout d'exécution
des sanctions tout ça est à chaque fois
balayé d'un revers de d'un revers de
main cette exécution des sanctions que
vous soulevez
eric dupond moretti est auditionné
aujourd'hui justement pour son projet de
loi pour redonner confiance en la
justice
est ce que les français ont raison de ne
plus faire confiance en leur justice
selon les sondages c'est plutôt le cas
les français vous savez ce n'est pas
qu'ils n'ont plus confiance dans les
juges qui remettent en question
l'institution judiciaire mais il ya deux
niveaux en fait de fait il ya les
moments où on voit vous avez décrit
certains quartiers certains lieux de
consommation de drogue
quand on voit qu'une interpellation fait
le matin pour des choses parfois très
graves avec parfois des violences contre
la police peut donner lieu à une
libération le soir même ou le lendemain
et qui revoit ses individus revenir dans
leur rue ou dans les quartiers
voilà légitimement c'est le cas
stalingrad hier les lézards et eu d une
évacuation et finalement les personnes
sont revenus quelques minutes plus tard
voilà bah quand ils voient ça ils
doutent de l'efficacité de la justice
mais les policiers eux-mêmes en viennent
à douter de leur du sens de l'oeuvre de
leur mission et la deuxième chose c'est
le fait est bien quand on voit
effectivement des gens des gens pour des
choses très graves qui sont condamnés à
des peines plus ou moins longue mais qui
parfois est bien soi ne les exécute pas
soit sont relâchés au bout de quelques
mois
et bien parce qu'on a des prisons qui
sont surchargés parce que l'exécution
des peines et les remises de peine
aujourd'hui fonctionne de telle manière
et bien légitimement on peut on peut
douter de la sévérité de la sanction
ce n'est pas l'autorité ou là où le
réalisme du juge qui sont remis en
question mais c'est le fonctionnement de
toute une chaîne d'exécution pénale qui
aujourd'hui est bien pour ce qu'ils sont
et revenons à la promesse originelle des
manuels macron qui était la même que
celle de françois fillon est que tous
les candidats création de 15000 places
de prisons sur le quinquennat
non pas les lancers mais les créer
aujourd'hui on en est à 1600 1700 à
peine péniblement ça veut dire un
dixième de la promesse et il reste un an
et on sait très bien qu'elle ne sera pas
tenu conséquence pendant la période du
coville d'insister un volume de
libération anticipée de détenus qui n'a
été jamais vu et bien entendu certains
d'entre eux ont pas si bill et ça a fait
les choux gras de la presse que c'est
des choses qui sont proprement
inacceptable
fabien defilippo on va parler d'être la
polémique pour les républicains pour les
régionales en paca alors rebondissement
hier puisque d'abord renaud muselier a
dit qu'il n'y aurait finalement pas
d'accord avec en marche et le bureau
politique finalement elle a confirmé
comme candidat à écouter ce qu'a dit
renaud muselier hier je veux redire
clairement comme je les dis depuis le
début qu'il n'y a pas et il n'y aura pas
d'accord à quelques niveaux que ce soit
avec en marche
pas plus qu'avec d'autres appareils mais
je suis sensible à tous les soutiens qui
se manifeste à tout est rentré dans
l'ordre
comment vous l'expliquez je pense que
l'église a été remise au milieu du
village et c'était nécessaire
renaud muselier est tombé dans un piège
il a fait une faute morale et politique
dans tombant dans le piège de jean
castex qui avec beaucoup de cynisme et
sa mise en scène du jdd de dimanche l'a
mis au pied du mur
maintenant je me félicite depuis
dimanche la réaction unanime de tous les
républicains qui ont dénoncé cet accord
dans la région sud est qui ont mis
renaud muselier face à ses
responsabilités il faut choisir on ne
peut pas être le candidat ait des
républicains et en même temps de la
république en marche une envie dans ces
cas là at emmanuel macron et c'est fini
renaud muselier est revenu en arrière
il a clarifié les choses il a expliqué
qu'il ne prendrait pas de candidat élu
député ou de ministre de la république
en marche
c'est des choses qui sont essentiels
pour nous et donc l'arroseur arrosé dans
cette histoire c'est un peu le premier
ministre jean castex qui avec tambours
et trompettes annoncé avoir fragmenter
la droite mais aujourd'hui la droite le
rejette clairement lui l'échec de sa
politique
muselier est tombé dans un piège il est
pourtant pas novice en politique renaud
muselier c'était que c'était tout de
même son attention vous pensez que ce
genre de l'histoire va se répéter
je pense qu'elle va servir d'exemple à
beaucoup de gens et ils savent
aujourd'hui que les républicains prône
une clarté pour leur candidature et on
ne veut pas du tout d'ambiguïté avec des
gens qui ont conduit la politique celle
qu'on décrivait pas plus tard que dans
la question d'avant et qu'il met la
france dans une situation d'échec
du point de vue sécuritaire mais aussi
du point de vue économique et du point
de vue de l'office
c'est palpable et c'est peut-être qu
officiellement c'est la position
affichée chez les républicains mais tout
le monde n'est pas d'accord
certains disent oui il y à des
convergences avec la république en
marche mais l'est-elle dites moi moi je
veux bien entendre mais il faut dire qui
et sur quel sujet parce que ça je n'ai
pas entendu que vous trouviez des points
communs sur toute une mandature
il assure même mois l'assemblée
nationale en tant qu'opposant il ya des
textes qui font consensus pour l'intérêt
général mais qui font consensus aussi à
gauche et dans tous les partis
eh bien on n'a pas de difficulté à aller
voter mais sur l'essentiel de ce qu'on
en valeur de son sont nos valeurs sur
l'essentiel de ce qu'est notre vision
pour le pays mais je suis depuis quatre
ans à l'assemblée nationale au contact
le plus proche du groupe de la
république en marche
je vous assure qu' il n'y a absolument
pas de possibilité de gouverner de
gouverner ensemble
et si vous parlez maintenant des gens
qui sont partis de chez nous pour aller
à la république en marche mais jamais
aucun des partis en disant ah les
valeurs de la république en marche sont
très bonnes leur projet meilleur juive
et non à chaque fois qu'ils sont partis
c'était pour sauver un poste ou pour
récupérer un poste au gouvernement
je crois qu'on peut légitimement douter
des motivations profondes de ces
personnes là on va parler de la vente
des rafale à l'egypte florence parly
ministre des armées s'est félicité de la
vente de 30 rafale de la france à
l'egypte pourtant paris n'a pas encore
été vraiment touchée la la somme de 4
milliards d'euros justement pour cette
vente ce sera un prêt des banques
françaises écouter d'avoir la ministre
des armées on en parle après je me
félicite de la vente de 30 rafale à
l'egypte partenaire stratégique
ce succès à l'export est crucial pour
notre souveraineté et le maintien de
7000 emplois industriels en france
pendant trois ans le rafale démontre à
nouveau son excellence technologique et
opérationnel un prêt donc des banques
françaises garantis par l'état pour que
l'egypte puisse acheter ces rafales vous
qu'on sait que l'egypte a les moyens ou
remboursé oui oui c'est des choses qui
sont étalés sur une longue période ce
n'est pas le premier contrat de ce type
qui est passé avec l'egypte
c'est important à la fois d'avoir une
technologie française qui s'exporte à
travers le monde et en matière militaire
des savoir faire qui sont reconnues
internationalement c'est important aussi
de pérenniser une production
industrielle sur un produit qui est
fabriqué sur notre sur notre sol
derrière bien sûr quand on parle de
telles sommes 4 milliards d'euros
et bien il y a des facilités de paiement
qui sont octroyés aux clients savons en
matière militaire mais comme ça vaut
pour n'importe quel pour n'importe quel
produit avec des prêts à la consommation
qu'on retrouverait dans le cadre privé
même si la csn échelle vraiment plus
gigantesque que ça mais c'est des choses
qui sont qui sont courantes et quand on
travaille avec des partenaires
stratégiques dans la longue durée on a
un recul on a un recul là dessus il ya
des choses qui sont prévus pour
sécuriser ses contrats là et c'est bien
c'est bien normal
est-ce qui est ce qui est prévu pour
sécuriser c'est peut-être la
participation oscille et des alliés
comme les aimait ratier qui sont prêts à
mettre la main à la poche
oui oui oui
dans ces cas là vous savez et bien c'est
des systèmes de plus en plus qu'ils sont
qui sont polis nationaux et qui amène
plusieurs pays à mettre en commun leurs
moyens
je pense que c'est une région du monde
où c'est important de pouvoir s'appuyer
sur des sur des partenaires sur des
partenaires stratégiques et en tout cas
pour l'industrie française en ce qui
nous concerne directement
c'est plutôt un succès dont il faut ce
qu'il faut aussi féliciter
fabien defilippo aujourd'hui c'est le
bicentenaire de la mort de napoléon
emmanuel macron elle va se rendre aux
invalides pour déposer une gerbe de
fleurs beaucoup s'opposent justement à
cette commémoration est ce que cette
polémique est justifiée selon vous non
elle n'est pas justifiée vous avez une
tendance à la relecture de l'histoire de
l'histoire de france de ce qu'ont fait
certains certains personnages vous avez
même aujourd'hui des gens qui remettent
en cause les dessins ni des dessins
animés de walt disney qu'on a regardé
dans notre enfance parce qu'ils seraient
ou racistes ou relevant de la prédation
sexuelle
donc tout ça va très très loin parce que
certains voudraient effacer ce qu'est
notre histoire ce que notre culture
il y à un récit national qui nous permet
de nous construire d'adhérer à des
valeurs communes de nous reconnaître
dans une nation ce sont des choses qu'il
faut absolument préserver
je ne dis pas qu'il faut pas être lucide
sur les erreurs qu'ont pu commettre
à un moment donné tel grands personnages
historiques mais ça c'est des choses
qu'on apprend à l'école et qui sont
enseignées avec impartialité et malgré
tout on peut reconnaître qu'à un moment
donné
eh bien oui il ya des grandes choses qui
ont été faites quand été fait pour la
pour l'enfance par différents
personnages et s'attaquer au statut pour
les déboulonner je crois que c'est le
fait d'individus qui veulent seulement
affaiblir la nation olivero on va parler
de la situation sanitaire un mot pour
finir olivier verront s'est montré
optimiste hier il était à sciences po et
il a donné des éléments plutôt plutôt
positif pour la suite
écoutez nous étions à 40 mille cas par
jour
nous sommes à 20 mille cas par jour et
nous baissons l'épidémie baisse de 20 à
25% par semaine au 15 jours nous
devrions donc être quelque part entre
dix et quinze mille cas par jour ce qui
nous permet de reprendre le contrôle sur
l'épidémie grâce au triptyque tester
alerté protéger est ce que vous y croyez
à cet optimisme certains scientifiques
disent quelle attention on pourrait même
avoir une recrudescence de l'épidémie
cet été on a un recul maintenant d'un an
on a vu que les chiffres avaient baissé
l'année dernière dans des proportions
importantes durant toute la période
estivale les températures tarde un peu à
remonter mais on constate que déjà les
courbes ont fléchi de manière de manière
importante
maintenant si on veut éviter que ça
remonte tôt ou tard parce que le virus
continue de circuler dans les écoles
dans les lieux de travail dans les
transports publics dans les familles il
faut être très pragmatique et maintenant
il faut dire au gouvernement chaque jour
le répéter que beaucoup de français ils
n'arrivent pas à accéder à des
rendez-vous pour la pour la vaccination
ceux qui le souhaitent doivent pouvoir y
accéder très rapidement et la hausse il
ya un vrai décalage entre leur annonce
est ce qu'on constate réellement est ce
que constate nos concitoyens / dr hibou
quand ils veulent être vaccinés par
rapport aux objectifs à fâches affiché
au départ mais même par rapport aux
objectifs des cas les trois fois déjà
on est encore loin du compte il faut le
reconnaître et ils doivent faire
confiance aux collectivités pour pouvoir
accélérer cette stratégie là là la
situation en moselle d'un mot elle
s'améliore également oui elle s'est
vraiment bien bien
il y aurait un tel point que la semaine
passée nous étions les départements du
grand est dans lequel le taux
d'incidence avaient le plus baissé
merci beaucoup fabien defilippo d'avoir
répondu ce matin en direct à nos
questions dans la matinale d'arreter
france